[Música]
[Aplausos]
sirve para encontar
para qué
y para alejar a los amigos
se puede dar de postre
lo siento
en los ojos de nuestra sociedad
ayuda
[Música]
[Aplausos]
to be de una garza moral
dándole combate un río
así es como se enamoran
[Música]
tu corazón con el mío
y yo vi de una cara esta mora dándole
bombas de un río
[Música]
así es como se enamora
y así es como se enamoran tu corazón con
el mío
[Música]
ante una luna luna luna luna llena
la muchacha
[Música]
dime
a más
[Música]
y no me deja
la luna me está mirando yo no sé lo que
me ve yo tengo la ropa limpia ayer tarde
la a la vez
en la luna me está mirando yo no sé lo
que me ve
[Música]
tengo la ropa limpia y yo tengo la ropa
limpia ayer tarde la a la vez
una luz
[Música]
una luna llena
a mí
i
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con una hoja de [ __ ]
[Música]
y miradas que quieras
llevasen un fragmento del aire de la
luna
para cuando tengo
y dale la llave de la luna a los tres ya
nos presentan
para los condenados
i
no hay mejores
entonces parecidas y contras
[Aplausos]
[Música]